all right so what's going on molly how
can i help my husband i love him i know
he loves me but
he is very vocal and feels that
he works much harder than me in pretty
much all aspects of our lives
he has refused to talk to a marriage
counselor he's even threatened divorce
because he feels that i'm not working
hard enough in
um again all aspects of our life
including parenting and so i don't
really know what to do
since i've tried talking to him and i've
tried marriage
like offering marriage counseling i've
seen a counselor myself
so molly what does he want you to do
um what's he like when he sits down like
when he sits down and looks at you
what does he like list out because this
sounds like one of those idiots
is a list maker what is the list he's
putting out there that you're not living
up to
um the list it's everything so
everything from
just house chores to laundry dishes
down to finances you know and paying
bills
to parenting about how we're raising our
two daughters and what i'm not doing
correctly according to him um
and it it's difficult because you can
tell that he doesn't talk about things
he waits until he's frustrated about
something and then he kind of just blows
everything up
all at once what is your intimate life
like
um it's off and on depending on these
blow-ups
okay so we'll go about two weeks and
everything's
great we're intimate we're smiling we're
laughing
and then all of a sudden there's
something on his list
like this week it's laundry um
so what did you do what did you do what
did you do wrong with the laundry molly
like how did you according to him i
worked
so i worked 40 hours a week um we have
two daughters and
um he works out of town okay and so when
he comes home at the end of the week
um i don't have all the laundry folded
because i work 40 hours a week and i'm
taking care of our two daughters it's
ridiculous
that's ridiculous i'm just kidding go
ahead so
but yeah when he comes home it's not
done and he's he gets very vocal about
how there's too many clothes
that aren't clean or put away so
anytime somebody whether it's a friend
of mine whether it's myself
whether it's um somebody in this
situation like on the radio or
an old counseling client my first
question is always this
is he right
um he does have some grounds for some of
it absolutely
and i do vocalize yeah the laundry is
not folded
no no no no no that's silly
right so like the the actual nuts and
bolts
right that's i mean those are
checklist things those aren't those
aren't
roots those aren't virtues right i'm
talking less about
because those type of nitpicky things
are are a coward's way of saying
you're not the wife that i want or
you're not living up to this
imaginary fictional human that i've got
in my head
or they are have delusions of grandeur
so they're off doing their job
and quite honestly they're probably
really busy they're probably exhausted
fill in the blank
probably not as tired as a 40-hour week
single mom at home with two kids
um but tired nonetheless and they come
home
and they get on the airplane or they get
in their car and they have this fantasy
of what the home's gonna look like and
then that picture doesn't match the
picture in their head and then they
throw a temper tantrum
and so that's i'm talking about the the
virtue part here
that's he's saying you are not the
partner
that i was hoping for and you are not
living up to the partnership that we
agreed on or that i'm demanding and so
my first
question always is is he right
are you a self-sabotaging wife or are
you somebody who's not interested in
having a partnership with him are you um
getting home from work and just saying
i'm not doing nothing forget all this
like is that is there accuracy there no
absolutely not all right cool so before
i go after somebody
then i just want to i want to get that
part out of the way because here's a
great example
i had a i was not a great boyfriend in
college
and though i was dating somebody who's
now my wife and
um we got into a tiff and i came home
i'll never forget this i walked into my
house and there was
it was this wacky apartment on top of a
building downtown and
i walked in and my buddies were watching
tv or whatever and i said something
along the lines of
this girl who's now my wife said i was a
jerk and
or i was an idiot or whatever can you
believe that
and then my buddy trevor who's still to
this day one of my best friends on
planet earth
goes are you being serious you're like
the biggest jerk i've ever met and i was
like what i
i thought i was the kindest guy and he's
like no
are you being for real and so i was in
that moment right
in a moment of reflection um by the way
everybody needs honest friends like that
that's why i still love him
is because he was right you know i had
to look in the mirror and say
no i i am i'm not handling these things
right but you have done that and it's
not you
right correct okay
so what's your what's your ultimate
question you've got it you're in a
situation now you can't win
you've got somebody who's got delusions
of grandeur you've got somebody who has
made it their life mission to make sure
you know your place and your place is
going to be below me
in a place where you can't win so and
you've got two daughters who are
absorbing
every second of this and whether they
want to or not are
learning this is what marriage looks
like and this is what a husband who says
quote unquote i love you and your mom
treats how they treat people
and so what's your question
the biggest thing is how do i get him
to understand that marriage counseling
or just
counseling for himself for whatever it
is that's bothering him so much
would help him because you can't come
home and he might be tired
oh no yeah you can't there's nothing you
can do
to make him change he's going to have to
decide
i want to have a partnership with my
wife that we
are going to become one in this
adventure journey raising kids and being
married
and being together and having a great
sex life and a great communication life
and
lots of laughter and as much joy as this
crummy world will give us he's got to
decide that on his own
you can and you've probably done this
and so here's a couple things i'm
rattling off top of my head
you can
have a conversation with him that's not
that's pretense
right um pre blow up pre-fight
pre-frustration you can have that
conversation upstream
and you've probably heard me say a
thousand times and i'll say it a
thousand times more
you can have a meal and go somewhere you
can go get a bed and breakfast one night
and just get away and tell them that you
want to have a retreat my wife and i
just did that recently to start the new
year we did that every year we have a
retreat
and this year like most years it was
teary we laughed a lot we had to have
some hard conversations with one another
but we're just putting out there we're
just being vulnerable and honest you may
have already done that have you already
had those hard conversations
i've tried to okay they usually don't
they they're usually one-sided usually
i'm the one talking and he
walks away or changes the subject okay
so when you
when you said he's threatened divorce
like an idiot
yeah uh i don't mean to talk bad about
your husband but people like no i'm just
gonna be
shut up dude so does
does he is he serious about it
he threatened it once um a couple weeks
ago
and he seemed pretty serious about it
okay and so i
kind of let him play that you know if he
wanted
if he was that unhappy i told him you
know i don't want him to be happy so i
let him play through with it
and then of course he realized that he
was an idiot and
um just we had our two weeks of
good relationship where he listened to
me and he
apologized partially to me you know as
best that he knows how to apologize and
and we moved on
from that two weeks and then it all
started over again
minus the threats of divorce so
here's what i want you to do i want you
to work you're in counseling now you
have a therapist now
yes okay i want you to when do you see
your counselor next
um i'm not on the schedule yet i usually
do every two weeks okay
so the next time you go see your
counselor i want you to show up with a
list
and i want you to tell your counselor
today i want to
you to help me solidify and draw
firm boundaries that i'm going to
communicate in a hard conversation with
my husband
and what that's going to look like are
things like
you will not threaten divorce in this
house
you will not belittle me in front of my
daughters
if you want something done a certain way
we're going to talk about it and i'm
going to let you know that i want to
honor
you i want to be a great partner here
and you're going to honor me because
sometimes my 40-hour week job
and one of our two daughters and or both
daughters have some struggles and life
happens
and you're not going to talk to me that
way anymore
because i deserve more i'm worth more
our
daughters cannot watch this nonsense
because i need you to hear me say kids
absorb
yelling they absorb that fight they
absorb that tension
and they blame themselves and your
daughters are growing up in a situation
where for the rest of their life they're
going to try to figure out how to make
sure the man in their life
is doing okay and you know the road that
will put them on
right and this is
a hard reality i understand that i'm not
making light of this this is hard hard
hard hard hard
but the the the hard conversation has to
start with
both of your feet firmly planted on the
floor which means i want you to get with
your counselor and draw these boundaries
out to a t
you will not talk to me that way anymore
period
and here is the way this is gonna look
and you're gonna have to have an or what
right in counseling we always talk about
you have to have an or what because he
may say well forget you then
and you're gonna have to have those
boundaries drawn and you're gonna have
to have
your next counseling appointment already
ready to rock and roll but i want you to
begin to put but not begin i want you to
firmly plant both feet on the ground
you've done the hard work of looking in
the mirror and saying is this me or not
and you said no it's not it's
unreasonable i'm being attacked every
day
every couple of weeks the guy in my life
throws a temper tantrum the guy who
swore he's gonna love me and protect my
daughters
chooses to go to war because he's a
grown-up child
and this is gonna be the season that you
say no more 20 21 is gonna be the season
that
that you say molly no more you're not
gonna talk to me that way i'm gonna
treat us that way
and so there's what i want you to do
have that conversation with your
therapist
have the conversation with your husband
please don't do it in the middle of a
fight
plan it let him know it's coming tell
him that you are still reeling from the
declaration that i want to divorce
and that you want to follow up with him
about that and that's when you were
going to take a bold step
and say here's who we are going to be in
this house and i love you and i
desperately want to
fight fight fight for this marriage
but i'm not gonna fight myself i'm not
gonna fight somebody who keeps turning
their back on us
so molly let me know how those
conversations go um we'll be thinking
about you
those are hard you're in a hard hard
situation
and by the way to everybody when
somebody comes at you
with you're not this you're not
upholding that
you are the worst fill in the blank you
screwed this up you're an idiot
whatever i learned this from
a young employee of mine a decade or
more ago and
i asked him his name's jordan bunch he's
an extraordinary guy he lives in dallas
i think or somewhere
in central texas i'll never forget i
asked him just in passing
here i was i was his boss right and i i
ended up walking away from that
conversation learning more than i'd
learned that year i
said man you're always so peaceful even
when when you're you're frustrated
you're always so peaceful
how do you remain so at peace in these
hard
conversations and these hard moments and
he said something that has stuck with me
ever since
he said anytime somebody comes at me
with an accusation they come at me angry
the first thing i do
is i look in the mirror and i ask myself
what am i contributing to this problem
what did i contribute to this
is this right and i thought man what a
great way to approach
life and and not to constantly be
blaming yourself and shaming yourself
and taking overblame like
it's probably me no not that but just
stopping for a second and
saying am i being a jerk right and
make sure you've got people in your life
like trevor who i love who will tell you
like my buddy todd like my buddy john my
buddy kevin who will tell you
hey man we don't do that don't be that
guy don't act like that don't say that
everybody's gotta have people in their
life that will hold them accountable and
say
you're not the one this is not molly
this is not molly molly's doing right
look in the mirror folks and then you
gotta make hard calls and draw hard hard
boundaries